nous avons des faits la superpuissance
l'afghanistan et le cimetière des
superpuissances est ce qu ont chanté des
talibans en tenue traditionnelle alors
que les derniers soldats américains sont
soit les la nuit dernière ce départ
bâclé précipité est il le fruit d'une
politique extérieure désastreuse et une
synonyme de retour à la case départ et
surtout comment imaginer maintenant
l'avenir décryptage de ce fiasco et de
ses conséquences avec nos invités
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
régis le sommier grand reporter
désormais arte france bienvenue régis
sur ce plateau à vos côtés nicholas
nicolas conc'air porte parole à des
républicains républicain overseas france
bonsoir à vous également nicolas
conc'air merci d'être avec nous alors
joe biden prend la parole ce soir deux
reports en 17h30 19h30 et maintenant
20h45 heure française
ça montre une certaine fébrilité de la
part du président américain nicholas
cronk r sinon américaine est en deuil et
depuis cette attaque terroriste qui lui
a coûté 13 militaires c'est au tour de
l'attaqué terroriste à kaboul occasion
également de nombreuses décès chez les
personnes si les reagan à ce moment là
déjà il avait tardé à s'exprimer et lors
de la cette prise de parole cette
conférence de presse voilà dit refuser
répondre à certaines questions ils
étaient hésitants bégayant du conte
c'était consternant c'était vraiment pas
une attitude de commandant en chef comme
on l'attend il a failli aux américains
et la faille aux états unis il a mis en
danger les algues en faisant serait très
précipitée on peut s'attendre encore une
fois que cette décalage des prises de
paroles soient là et me dit tu as une
fébrilité et un manque de courage et de
prise de responsabilité par rapport aux
torts qui sont les siens alors on
rappelle à noter ce top 14 il n'avait
pas compris que vous êtes évidemment
membres des républicains d'où évidemment
ce discours forcément un peu plus
partisan mais qui est important pour
pour l'analyse ce soir régis le sommier
joe biden qui a dit hier je porte toute
la responsabilité pour tout ce qui s'est
passé récemment que peut-on attendre de
cette prise de parole ce soir des
excuses
des justifications une tentative
peut-être de sauver la face donc je
crois pas enfin ce qu'on a vu dans ce
discours qui était effectivement pas
d'une facture exceptionnelle mais au
moins je baille donne à assumer ce choix
même si c'est pas lui il faut le
rappeler qu'il a enclenché ce qui s'est
passé en afghanistan a été enclenchée
dans les deux administrations
précédentes je rappelle que barack obama
une des raisons pour laquelle barack
obama a été élu c'est pas simplement
parce qu'il était charismatique qu'il
était un président nouveau qu'il
incarnait tout ce qu'on a dit sur lui
c'est parce que c'est un président anti
guerre et barack obama s'était engagé à
retirer les troupes américaines d'irak
ce qu'il a fait en 2010 qui a provoqué
une catastrophe à l'époque c'est à dire
le départ enfin la montée de l'état
islamique pour d'autres raisons mais en
tout cas ça a été le déclenchement et
puis là on s'aperçoit que deux
législatures après
les talibans sont au pouvoir donc on
peut légitimement aujourd'hui se poser
la question de savoir cette fameuse
guerre contre le terrorisme qui était la
marque de fabrique de george bush l'a
t'on vraiment gagner somme toute
sommes-nous aujourd'hui avec ce califat
islamique qui s'est implantée au coeur
de l'asie qui s'est réimplanté parce que
c'est il faut rappeler que le paradoxe
de tout ça c'est que à la différence des
russes quand il sort quand ils ont
évacué l'afghanistan en 1988 ils ont
laissé sur place une administration une
armée de 400000 sommes
unanimes une commande et universités ils
ont laissé un pays qui est évidemment
trois ans après qu'on l'a réussi quand
l'urss à comment a disparu ça a été la
guerre civile en afghanistan mais il y
avait cette administration
administration nadjib ghoul a
aujourd'hui ce que font les américains
s'est littéralement redonner les clés à
ceux qui sont venus chasser 20 ans avant
donc il ya zéro héritage américain en
afghanistan c'est à dire qu'on a on a
atteint le degré une absurdité totale et
donc on peut dire que ce qui se passe
aussi il faut regarder les choses de
façon
de façon plus globale c'est que les
américains ne sont plus intéressés par
l'afghanistan joe biden a été assez
clair là-dessus l'a dit on serait resté
cinq ans de plus ça n'aurait rien changé
le problème c'est que tous ces mots ce
millier de 2,2 milliards qui a été
investie dans ce pays l'a été en pure
perte et le sens de la mission avaient
complètement disparu au début il fallait
reconstruire le pays ensuite il y avait
une présence qui se faisaient et puis
l'incapacité surtout ça c'est notoire à
former et à faire que y est un
gouvernement en afghanistan inclusif qui
inclut toutes les parties de
l'afghanistan et ça ça a été un échec
total on va y revenir justement ce sens
au gouvernement parce qu'on a du mal
pour le moment à lui donner un visage à
nicolas conc'air registre sommet disais
à l'instant aucun héritage aussi ce
n'est que de 1 des armes un sacré une
sacrée armada d'armes laissé sur le
terrain on entend d'ailleurs dans votre
documentaire régissant vous avez passé
trois semaines à kaboul au mois de
juillet un taliban un petit peu mon cas
on nous dit en bas voilà on a les armes
américaines avant et bien c'est eux qui
les utilisent et maintenant on les
utilise contre eux c'est une vraie
humiliation pour les américains et vous
pour vous c'est haut débit de joe biden
uniquement absolument il faut lui mettre
ça à son débit il a porté la
responsabilité de l'abandon de ces
arsenaux militaires qui sont des
considérables ces armes qui vont
éventuellement se retrouver pour
retourner contre des militaires
américains des intérêts américains mais
également d'autres nations occidentales
et qui vont avoir vite fait d'être
propagées dans toute la zone il ya un
marché noir est alimentée différents
autres réseaux terroristes maintenant ce
qu'il faut bien intégrer c'est que
c'était vraiment à la charge du
contribuable américain qui est également
le sacrifice de tous les deux tout les
militaires morts pour de ses vingt ans
de guerre ses vingt-quatre mille soldats
américains qui ne sont pas morts en vain
ils ont voulu défendre ses libertés là
et qui nécessitent voilà de de frapper
fort et de réclamer de manière
volontaire et ferme l'ensemble de ces
équipements qui doivent être restitués
aux états unis alors que les soldats
américains auront quitté l'afghanistan
hier soir les talibans tout cas eux de
leur côté font déjà passer des messages
depuis plusieurs heures écouter leurs
porte parole
nous avons un message à l'intention de
tout envahisseur éventuel quiconque se
tourner vers l'afghanistan avec de
mauvaises intentions sera confronté à ce
que les états unis ont connu aujourd'hui
qu'elles sont cassés les dents l'ont
fait c'est depuis la nuit des temps
l'afghanistan et n'a jamais été conquis
par personne n'a grünigen is personne
n'a jamais contrôler l'afghanistan en
réalité ça veut pas dire qu' il n'y ait
pas d'envahisseurs qui sont passés
depuis l'époque de gengis khan alexandre
le grand tous les grands conquérants et
plusieurs fois parfois sont passés par
l'afghanistan ce qu'il faut comprendre
sur l'afghanistan et c'est un peu le
problème auquel sont confrontés les
talibans aujourd'hui notamment dans
leurs liens ou leurs rapports très
ambigu avec les groupes terroristes
c'est que les talibans ont remis sur la
charge de l'afghanistan on les voit
parader etc seront ils capables quand on
connaît l'histoire afghane d'asseoir
leur pouvoir sur l'ensemble de
l'afghanistan c'est bien le problème
toute la zone de l'est si des ch s'est
implanté dans les régions du kunar de
nangarhar du côté de jalalabad et cetera
prix les territoires c'est le les
talibans ont chassé des ch parce qu'ils
n'ont vu comme un groupe concurrent
deich est toujours présent un certain
nombre d'autres groupes y compris al
qaïda dont je rappelle les tailles avec
lequel les talibans n'ont jamais
formellement rompu les liens ça c'est
quand même une chose assez assez
importante a rappelé
les talibans l'afghanistan c'est un pays
ingouvernable un pays de vallée c'est un
pays de route il faut contrôler ces
routes ça c'est une chose mais le pays
en lui même à une structure de montagne
tellement escarpé qu'il est très
difficile d'asseoir asseoir une
souveraineté nécessairement tout à fait
et puis il peut il peut se produire
aussi une chose c'est que les talibans
on n'arrive pas à administrer
économiquement et en ce moment ils sont
en train de faire beaucoup d'appels du
pied à l'étranger les chinois ont pris
ou ont pris langue avec eux depuis très
longtemps les iraniens aussi on oublie
le successeur de souleymane il chez les
gardiens de la révolution était
précédemment un spécialiste de
l'afghanistan et donc les talibans ont
dialogué avec les iraniens et dialogue
évidemment avec les pics pakistanais qui
n'aurait fait qu'une chose c'est que
d'avoir un n 1 un afghanistan stable à
leurs frontières ça ça leur va très bien
ensuite les russes ont repris aux six
contacts avec les talibans donc en fait
le vide américain est en train d'être
comblé mais ça ne veut pas dire que le
gouvernement taliban même s'ils
s'appuient sur c est sûr c est ces
puissances étrangères même s'il a des
liens entre avec eux les turcs récemment
aussi pour l'administration de
l'aéroport après le départ des
américains ça ne veut pas dire que les
talibans auront les moyens d'administrer
économiquement et d'asseoir leur
souveraineté sur tout le pays c'est un
vrai problème parce que encore une fois
je dis c'est un pays instable c'est
quasiment fait un pays qui n'existe pas
nicolas conte car vous êtes un également
américains sauf erreur de ma part
comment réagit
régis la population américaine est ce qu
il voit un débat qu'une humiliation une
forme aussi de soulagement après les
images évidemment compliqué de ce
président devant devant les cercueils
des soldats morts un soulagement d'être
désormais loin cette guerre en premier
lieu c'est surtout de voir l'inaptitude
de joe biden à être le commandant en
chef des armées américaines et de
pouvoir asseoir l'autorité des états
unis dans la région et dans le monde on
sent qu'il ya vraiment un manque de
leadership qu'on a été habitué à mieux
ensuite la en ce qui concerne la gestion
de ce retrait d'afghanistan les sondages
sont à la limpide criant il serait
d'être gérés de manière différente
prolongée il fallait pas juste de tenir
un bout de papier à traiter et prolonger
de manière à ce que l'ensemble des
intérêts américains des civils nomadic
même à plus forte raison ceux qui ont
été des vendeurs des électeurs de
bayonne qui commence à voir au bout de
huit mois de mandature à quel point il
ya des insuffisances que ça soit projet
allait crise migratoire pour gérer une
crise économique et pour gérer un
retrait qui a pourtant été promis
commettre sans chaos sans heurts et
voilà la manière dont ils accusent gérer
sa vis-à-vis des cérémonies qui aurait
lieu dommage c'était absolument mais
détestable et pas du tout à la hauteur
d'un président moi je voudrais que
nuancer ce propos joe biden arrive bon
on prend la législature il ya très peu
de temps le vrai la vraie le vrai
basculement a lieu en 2018 quand donald
trump décide de retirer sept mille
troupes américaines et ce moment là les
talibans font calcul que
mathématiquement ça peut être en leur
faveur ils commencent leur offensive
dans les campagnes à ce moment là il ya
des zones qui n'ont jamais quitté on
imagine que les talibans ont été chassés
du pouvoir on voit effectivement tout
c'est en fait ils ont ils ont conservé
des zones rurales et ils ont commencé à
grignoter parce que ils se sont dit on a
un avantage numérique à ce moment là
c'est la volonté c'était la volonté
précédente et ça je suis d'accord avec
vous d'obama et de bail donne de se
retirer d'afghanistan
même s'il ya eu un sort déjà un moment
c'est à dire une augmentation du nombre
de troupes ensuite ça a été finalement
la décision et trump a accompagné le
mouvement mais quand on voit ce qui
s'est passé en février 2020 ou à doha
les américains négocient une paix avec
les talibans sans le gouvernement afghan
on peut se dire que ils ont déjà tiré un
trait sur le pays ça veut dire qu'ils ne
croient plus à la capacité du
gouvernement rani à l'époque 1 2 le
dernier gouvernement afghan 2 d'assurer
la situation ou en tout cas de ceux de
devenir autonome
il ya deux choses il ya deux choses il
ya effectivement ce que vous nous
décrivez est le retrait qui s'est
effectivement mal placé alors qu'entre
partage wyss a lieu un mois avant donc
la prise de kaboul on voit que les
talibans 8 leur communication c'est déjà
une chose quasiment fait et pourtant
tout rond sont surpris compris les
occidentaux c'est ça qu'on a du mal à
condition de 10,6 alors ce qui est
surtout effrayant c'est on réalise donc
quand on passe donc du temps avec les
taliban et on est allé aussi faire des
patrouilles avec l'armée et la police
afghanes c'est qu'en fait les talibans
administrent leurs zones administrées
leur zone en juillet des zones large
comme la province du wardak est très
très grand
tranquillement ils mettaient des
checkpoints sur la route quand d'amour
kandahar kaboul qu'il a le principal axe
de l'afghanistan c'est l'action
commerciale et chéquiers toutes les
voitures on les a accompagnés c'était
impressionnant parce que à côté dans la
ville voisine qui appartenait toujours
au gouvernement vous alliez un pauvre
colonel avec 150 bonhomme suréquipés
dans des véhicules blindés qui se
prenaient des rpg en permanence des
bombes sous la route qui vivait et
bunkérisé derrière des sacs de sable et
de l'autre côté les autres combattants
faut le rappeler sans gilet pare balles
sans casque et avec des sandales et ces
deux générations à trois générations
talibans qui ont enfin de talibans aux
moudjahidine avant qu'ils ont vaincus
l'empiré soviétique et aujourd'hui
l'empiré américain avec des sandales
faut le rappeler mais
donc déjà on sentait que il y avait ce
dernier verrou qui tenait kaboul est
indéfendable on le sert qui à bout les
toits a été est tombé 4 fois jamais sans
aucun combat voilà et toutes les villes
d'afghanistan sont tombées comme des
fruits mûrs en fait on se pose
aujourd'hui faut-il parler avec les
talibans comme d'ailleurs l'a dit
notamment emmanuel macron parce qu'en
tout cas eux sont très nous parler ils
ont même envie d'être des interlocuteurs
officiels écouter le porte parole
l'émirat islamique d'afghanistan
souhaite entretenir de bonnes relations
avec les américains par le biais de la
diplomatie
cependant les américains ont échoué ici
ils ont échoué du point de vue militaire
ils n'ont pas réussi à atteindre leurs
objectifs
mais l'émirat islamique d'afghanistan
veut avoir de bonnes relations avec le
monde entier au nom de la nation nous
voulons avoir des relations
diplomatiques solide avec tous y compris
les états unis nous voulons rétablir
progressivement de bonnes relations avec
les états unis
nicolas conc'air donald trump votre
poulain n'avait pas attendu il avait
déjà commencé à négocier avec les
talibans aujourd'hui clairement il faut
continuer ces négociations et en faire
des interlocuteurs quasi officiel
désormais au delà de ce tract à sion qui
ont été menées à doha dont on apparaît
tout à l'heure la vraie question c'est
est la stature de chef qu'incarnait
donald trump et pendant cette période là
il ya eu un répit ya pas eu de victimes
d'attentats qui ont été menées les
intérêts des américains était défendu
fermement et il est papa d'attac qui ont
été menées contre les intérêts
américains
la question c'est de rétablir une
pétition de force est d'être de ne pas
se faire dicter un code de conduite ou
des contreparties près les talibans donc
c'est vraiment ça qui l'a attendu de la
part de la vie des américains et du
commandant en chef j'en parlais tout à
l'heure cette communication hui les
indiens par des talibans on le voit
clairement tout est contrôlé il
s'apprête à devenir en tout cas ils le
souhaitent nos interlocuteurs ça vous
paraît surréaliste
finalement d'engager ce dialogue est ce
qu'il faut négocier parler le vrai
prophète le vrai problème c'est qu'elle
est le rapport entre les taliban et
l'islam radical c'est vrai qu'en fait la
doctrine talibane elle ne dépareille pas
d'elle de celle d'al qaïda ni même de
celle de dèche fondamentalement à part
le fait qu'ils affichent un nationalisme
c'est à dire quand vous discuté de ça
avec eux il vous dit ils vous disent
vous en europe vous êtes chrétien nous
ça nous va à partir du moment où vous
n'attaquez pas notre culture chez un
taliban culture égale religion donc ils
vous disent clairement si vous nous en
ne vous attaquez pas nous on vous
attaquerai pas nous ici c'est l'islam
voilà islam avec la charia etc etc
maintenant le problème c'est que au fil
de ces années il ya tous ces talibans
qui ont ces soixante quinze mille
combattants avaient un ennemi commun qui
étaient les états unis aujourd'hui
toutes ses factions on se retrouvait les
une face aux autres avec leur
sensibilité avec leurs différences
tribales parce que si on ne peut pas
comprendre l'afghanistan sans comprendre
les tribus sans comprendre le rôle des
anciens des tribus sans comprendre les
ethnies aussi je regardais tout à
l'heure les talibans viennent d'accorder
là il ya deux langues en afghanistan
vous avez le pachtoune et le dari le
pachto et le dari pardon et ils viennent
de dire que l'ouzbek sera également ne
conserver comme langue officielle donc
ça c'est un appel du pied aux minorités
qu'ils ont sur partie séduire la
différence de leur première conquête
d'afghanistan à 96 donc ils ont une
espèce de volonté inclusive maintenant
les radicaux chez les talibans se trouve
dans l'appareil militaire ce sont eux
qui ont gagné la bataille le mollah
baradar habile ou là tous ces gens là
c'est des communicants c'est des gens
qui d'ailleurs souvent fait d une idée
des études qui sont pas des talibans de
base qui viennent des campagnes donc là
qui va gagner quelques ailes france va
gagner et puis ils sont parfaitement
conscients et j'insiste là dessus sur le
fait qu'il faut qu'ils arrivent à faire
que l'afghanistan ils n'ont plus
beaucoup d'argent que l'afghanistan soit
un pays économiquement sain qu'ils
arrivent à gérer ça ce que dice n'avait
pas réussi à faire quant à l'époque du
califat même s'il avait mis beaucoup
d'attention essayer de faire une
structure étatique est ce que les
taliban en seront capables ça ça va
déterminer leur position par rapport aux
afghans et par rapport au monde il ya
quand même un message qui est terrible
c'est qu'on a un califat islamique au
milieu de l'asie pour les autres groupes
regardez quand les talibans conquis
kaboul à il libre donc les le groupe
djihadiste qui tient la dernière zone de
syrie au nord ouest s'était vivent nos
frères talibans donc au niveau de
l'impact que cela peut avoir sur la
mouvance jihadiste c'est énorme qui
contrôle un pays voilà et que
fondamentalement au niveau de
l'idéologie ils sont pas très éloignées
voilà le mot de la fin pour vous est-ce
qu aux états unis on craint désormais de
nouveaux attentats
après le retrait des américains en
afghanistan où finalement ça n'a rien à
voir et comme le dit régis les taliban
resteront chez eux finalement avec leur
propre agenda indéniablement les
intérêts américains vont continuer à
être visé à faire l'objet de risque
d'attentât joe biden le reconnaît
lui-même c'est devenir incessantes
imminente con ce qui concerne le
rapatriement massif de personnalités
afghanes et aspirer que parmi eux ne
figure pas des potentiels terroristes et
qui vient se superposer à une crise
migratoire qui a lieu même au niveau
national aux états unis avec la
frontière sud qui vraiment meta risque
voilà l'ensemble de la stabilité et la
paix sur le territoire américain merci
en tout cas tous les deux nicolas franck
et régis le sommier merci d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce décryptage alors qu'on
attend toujours la prise de parole de
joe biden se dresse normalement dans un
quart d'heure mais encore une fois il a
été ajourné deux fois merci à vous deux